we're going to try and call timothy
chalamet
yo yo
i am calling the wonderful andrew
garfield i was like what the [ __ ] is tom
doing tom holland is calling his famous
friends live on the air
sit down stand up
sit down stand up
yeah that's tom hanging out with greg
james on bbc radio 1 in london they team
up to play a game called you guessed it
sit down stand up the rules are pretty
self-explanatory just call up a friend
and make a guess first up british rapper
stormzy i think he's standing up okay go
on
[Music]
are you standing up or sitting down
i'm sitting down
i said he's sitting down is that stormzy
yeah stormjay
how you doing
next it's timothy chalamet i think he is
sitting down
i'll go for standing up the first time
around the 26 year old actor doesn't
answer
no he's at work he's shooting
but later tom gets a call back
yo yo are you standing up or sitting
down i'm sitting down right now yes
after explaining why he called tom and
timothy catch up and even make plans to
hang out
how are you mate
chilling at work about to start another
beautiful day wonderful no complaints
life is good how are you doing i'm good
matey listen i'm in london this week
we're working in town so if you're about
to want to grab a bite uh let's do it
let's do it brother have a great day man
likewise mate lots of love speak to you
soon and then tom sets spider-man loving
hearts on fire when he dials his
honorary big bro i am calling the
wonderful andrew garfield
okay
right need to do a guess let's do it
again what do you think take note
sitting down i'm gonna say standing then
come on andrew
i think he's in america it's 4 45 a.m
it's early yeah okay brilliant that
didn't that didn't go down very well
okay so there was that whole eight hour
time difference thing but later in a
separate interview andrew reacts to the
whole ordeal and i'm like
bro i need to text him ask what that was
about because i don't know because at
3am my time must have been
early his time so he wasn't he wasn't he
would have been drunk believe it or not
i was in the room when he did it
[Laughter]
he was about to call you up
to ask whether you were sitting down or
standing up
for a ridiculous radio one game and for
the tick tick boom star hindsight is 20
20. oh my god i wish i had answered oh
my god i was i was i was asleep and i
heard that i had like
my phone buzzing i was like who the [ __ ]
is that and then i woke up the next
morning i was like what the [ __ ] is tom
doing i should have known it was you
it's pretty clear to see tom and andrew
are pals for life thanks to their unique
spider-man connection andrew recently
teamed up with fellow spidey toby
maguire for an epic surprise cameo in
the latest superhero flick spider-man no
way home it was just a really beautiful
thing to share together and to find a
brotherhood with toby as well and with
tom and the fact that we have shared
that we do share a very unique
experience and when et spoke with the
oscar nominee in january
once the secret was already out he
opened up about the magical experience
of working alongside his spider-man
brothers the fact that i get to be one
of those people wearing the suit next to
my actual
spider-man hero toby maguire and the
brilliant incredibly talented heartfelt
funny good sweet perfect spider-man of
tom holland and i get to be the middle
brother and i get to be like in awe of
my older brother and in full longing to
protect my younger brother it was really
about tom and tom's character tom's
peter tom's journey
as them as the center that and we were
just there to kind of support and have a
lot of fun and it was so much
goddamn fun
[Music]